mind your decisions i'm presh talwalkar
simplify the following expression
log base 2 of 3 multiplied by log base 3
of 4 multiplied by log base 4 of 5 and
so on until the final term log base 127
of 128
i adapted this problem from a post i saw
on reddit homework help
pause if you'd like to give this problem
a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
recall the change of base formula for
logarithms
log base b of u is equal to log base a
of u divided by log base a of b
this is for u greater than zero and a
and b positive real numbers that are not
equal to one
for the special case where a is equal to
e
we simplify this to the natural log of u
over the natural log of b
we'll use this version of the formula to
simplify this product
the first term becomes the natural log
of 3 over the natural log of 2. the
second term becomes the natural log of 4
over the natural log of 3.
we continue to apply this formula all
the way to the very end of this product
we then notice an interesting pattern
natural log of 3 in the numerator of the
first term will cancel with natural log
of 3 in the denominator of the second
term
then the natural log of 4 will cancel
out between the 2nd and third terms and
this pattern will continue all the way
to the very final term
the pattern is reminiscent of a
retracting telescope where only the very
beginning and the very end survive
for this reason it's known as a
telescoping product
only the very beginning and the very end
survive
we can then simplify this formula one
more time using the change of base
formula
the natural log of 128 over the natural
log of 2 will be equal to log base 2 of
128. 128 is equal to 2 to the power 7
and therefore this simplifies to be 7
and that's our answer
i love how this problem miraculously
simplifies
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube
as always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
you